okay four people joining this meeting it
is part of our infinite series of
incremental language developed no this
is not this is a language completeness
and consistency meeting Wow okay um so
let's see oh boy
what is the first item here this looks
painful it was fake for tableview of
datasets to evaluate yes this is
apparently something that was put in at
the very end of the 12:1 development
cycle but it's a necessary feature why
is it why is it a necessary feature
because what you want to do I mean it's
what you want you're not gonna have
people indirectly say X equals data set
table view of dynamic of X nobody will
ever use it I mean this is basically a
yeah yeah well but people also don't I
mean I don't think people should do that
either I mean okay let's get a data set
and let's look at what we're talking
about him I mean it's a very nice
feature to be able to basically make a
data set editable well well if that's
what you wanted to do right you could do
what else could you do right that this
is the first I've heard of it but from
the sound of things I'm horrified that
I'm viewing a data set and then I
accidentally type into it the table view
cell or something and now my dataset has
changed I really hope that's not true it
is I mean it's no longer a data set if
you look at no way which is what which
is what the dynamic of data set would
have done right exactly yes I don't know
that would have worked wait no that
wouldn't work I mean you know we could
talk about whether it should work but it
doesn't work now right I mean so to make
that work we would have to basically
have
you know mutability of data sets and
data sets are right now not mutable i
mean data sets there's no operation that
says i mean if i say of a data set here
so let's say this is a data set um I
don't even know what happens if I say
prepend - well then you get a new data
set well but I have no idea what it even
I mean can I in fact pretend so let's
imagine that I have a data set that I
make from some very simple okay so now I
say prepend - yes - XY okay so have a
new data set now so with table view so I
mean if I did I don't even know if this
works if I do data set sub sub 1 2
equals zzzzz okay I don't understand why
that said that I don't think it can be
an l-value anybody know probably because
it was implemented on the cheap and
that's right so I mean it's not
transparent right data set is not
transparent to part and so since the
data set is marked marking itself as
atomic then it's saying you know right
so so the prepend who works via up
values it's not actually working through
any deep support so I see so it's a
specific data set up value is that what
you're telling me yes I see as Chris
calls on here
he requested not to be but
it's not very helpful but yeah um well
okay so right but but my point is that
first of all right we're already getting
confusing you know questions from people
of like you know why does data set of or
sorry why does table view of you know
list a list list a B not format no it
shouldn't look Stephen Stephen table
viewers are control the default to
control type is string right the strings
so strings and numbers things and
numbers yeah okay fair enough
but but you know what okay there is a
very useful object which is an editable
table this is what you know that's
aren't table the whole power Stephen the
whole power of of data set is that they
can deal with non tabular so why okay
why do you want to work we can the bread
let me finish my sentence I go I do want
it why do you want we can the brand by
suggesting its equivalent to something
that's inherently tabular okay that's
not the point okay so look let's look at
multiple things that we have that are
all kind of overlapping in bizarre ways
okay this is tabular stuff okay what do
we have we have grid okay which is
editable like this right which is
editable in kind of a table view like
way right yes it's the same type of
thing we can do you know I can add a
column I can add a row I can do this
setter etcetera etc and I assume that in
table view here if I were to do it it's
it is typesetting but it is not a
control I understand that but this
control obsession I I think let's forget
about that okay so here's a question why
does control return not add a row to a
table view
well you mean insert a row because
normally of course you don't need to add
right you have an infinite number of
rows done that but I might want how
would I how would I shift down a row how
would I shift what's in six to seven so
I don't remember if there's something in
the contextual menu but there are
reasons this is still experimental so
the you know your average J random
spreadsheet you would do use a menu
command insert row or insert column
yeah and that's I don't think there's I
don't think there's typically a keyboard
shortcut for it but they're definitely
menu commands for it but I mean that we
have an obvious keyboard shortcut right
I mean we have a okay unless unless you
have what happens if you have inside of
your table view a grid in a cell then
which which guy gets that shortcut that
I think is a John issue and I think he
would have a solution to that but I'm
not sure I mean it is certainly a
question that I would consider quite
quickly yeah um okay so so let me just
list off what we have and then we're
gonna list what things they do okay
we've got grid we've got data set we've
got what we've got a naked list an
association okay and then we've got
table for you here do we have anything
else
well we've also got me slightly you know
well we have power yeah we've got well
we've got row column
well the row column grid are all the
same same story
well row is actually really quite
different from grid and column yeah no
row is not at all the same as column
okay so we have yet another thing which
is kind of rough
yeah and well Rho is Rho is to clean up
version of sequence form so it's really
not you know it's really a typesetting
thing yeah okay so in addition to this
we have things like table form which by
the way I've just been playing around
with here in the last few minutes and
there are some interesting properties in
terms of how it interacts with other
things I don't know how much you want to
dig into that for answering these
questions but like data set of table
form produces a data set with the table
form strips table view of table form
does not type set but strips the table
form I'm sure no I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
doing percent type thing yeah yeah and
actually I should there's there's a
question for table form when should
function strip it eg data set strip it
and I would argue I mean I hadn't even
thought of that but I would argue that
that would be a common thing to want to
do although generally speaking write
functions don't strip table form or form
right and by the way I said the wrong
thing about table the table view does
strip table so both data set and table
view are stripping table form I don't
know I don't fully understand the
mechanism I mean if that's just a table
form of ABCD
yeah okay III that worked that looks to
me like a data set of one element yeah I
think that's in the data set of one
element if I do
oh sorry maybe I'm misinterpreting the
info form here I don't have enough yeah
then it's not doing anything it's just
taking it in one gulp
okay umm right then I doubt that tables
who doesn't another point we made on the
live stream by call is the gallery view
is another thing a bit like this
although gallery view is web-only
and not really very well specified
although it should be available in the
right and we asked the web team for a
specification than so that we could
implement it and we never got one so
okay so
gallery view does not make it sound like
it to control you know so this is
probably not a control okay there's a
separate issue which is getting the
specs from the web team that was I think
Ricardo was the implementer of this so I
think he's the one to push on that okay
yes can somebody do that yes okay okay
okay
all right okay so which can be L values
basically nothing here can be a null
value there correct
well except the list in this list can be
an l-value listen association can be all
values right yeah well yes well let's
certainly can and you know association
with certain random exceptions I think
also can and then and then tableview as
a control works as a kind of an l-value
okay all right so those can be all
values but now table view table view is
an l-value in the sense that any control
is an is an L value like slider yeah I
mean I don't look okay so let's be clear
I think there's a very useful piece of
functionality which is an editable table
that has nothing to do with it being a
control right that is that is very much
more like grid functionality because
grid is effectively a you know you can
edit it it you know displays and it's
editable but it's definitely not an
l-value
not an l-value not a I mean if I were to
say let me just understand something if
I were to say you know Z Z Z equals
whatever ABCD and then I were to say
dynamic I see so the difference is if I
say dynamic of grid of Z Z Z I get that
if I change the Z Z here I will get that
okay all good but what doesn't work is a
grid of dynamic of Z Z Z right because
grid is not a control
okay so that will do nothing I will just
come back as grid of that because it
doesn't it can't read through the
dynamic right right right
it's like this typeset is a dynamic box
not as a dynamic value okay
um okay so now table view on the other
hand in the same setup would be if I say
table view of Z Z Z what do you need the
second argument expression because the
default control type is strings and
numbers right until more obscure no
message nothing but why was that no
message it's generally speaking types of
things and basically the point here III
agree that there's some confusion around
this and we haven't resolved how to how
to deal with it but I so I think there
probably are two things here I think
that we have essentially the same code
same functionality but I think there are
two different kinds of operations I
think one is this control thing which I
think is really an expert programmer
story okay and the other is the I've
just got something that is like a grid
that I want to be able to edit but I
want it to be have different editing
controls than a grid and where the main
use I'm gonna make of it is I'm gonna
shift enter the thing and well I mean if
I shift enter this right it'll give you
a table views ya and evaluates to itself
okay which is okay I mean okay so all
those things but if I say table view of
let's say 1 2 3 4 hopefully this will
now work because it's actual numbers yes
okay good yeah okay now if I want to get
out the payload I can presumably say
normal of that right I could also say
setting presumably of what of
percent 47 because it's a control and I
will get that yeah okay so now to me I
mean and I think we haven't really
internalized this point properly you
know I think it is very very useful to
just I mean okay the question is I mean
that there's a useful thing here just
typing random stuff in hitting with no
yeah what the heck happened that well is
it
it's got empty although they're not
uniformly emptied that's the tableview
look if it can be displayed here's my
point of view if the thing displays wait
wait wait no I'm no I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry that's not a bug the reason is
because it's empty rows its rows with
zero elements and and we're allowing
ragged you know ragged Rolex so it's a
ragged row length with two rows that
have zero elements in them so what so
why isn't it displaying as a table view
I don't think it has no oh I'm sorry
your question is why isn't display as
the tail of you yes okay all right okay
so it should display as a table view so
in general anything you can enter in a
table view if I type shift enter it will
just come back as itself right yeah okay
so I can imagine that there is if we got
rid of our thinking about this as a
control and we you know maybe we'll
branch the names I'm not sure what we're
gonna do right but I could imagine that
just like a bunch of other things just
like a manipulate for example has that
button that says paste you know paste me
be sure I'm saying that I could imagine
that this could also have a paste me
button that is the equivalent of doing
normal of the thing right yes yes okay
so I mean if we do this then just to
remind ourselves what's going on here we
would say paste snapshot okay though
that comes back as that
although I think what we really want
here is yeah I mean it's just a pace
that pastes the payload um
now here's another question what happens
why does tableview not allow does
tableview allow header names column
names
it will okay okay so that so then yeah
then okay so it that was feature we
couldn't quite clean up okay so will
around lok row column names yeah like
like data set okay now the big
difference from data set why is it
different from data set different from
data set by being by being 2d and having
blank elements well well it's not just
that it's 2d it's sort of inherently
tabular right I mean so for example
consider this example so do data set you
know and give it an association a goes
to the Association B goes to C and make
them strings just to be on the safe side
okay and yeah and - yeah just close that
and now do table view of percent oh it's
that you're gonna have to add expression
again because of this I don't I don't
know how this he's gonna come through
but yeah that's wild right what the heck
did it do that why does it drill down I
mean what happens if I do table view of
the Titanic that's what I did here so so
what happens if I take one of these
hierarchical data sets table view so the
idea is that it's doing effectively
normal in both direction okay hold on a
little Evan look at this for a second so
you're saying that if I do let's say I
say example data what was all that junk
by the way and I'm sorry what was all
that junk that's all da key tools okay
example data data set and then oops and
then I say the planet's data set for
example so that's a hierarchical data
set okay so now let's imagine I do table
view of this it's gonna make a you know
an animal breakfast or something yeah
garbage what the heck is that
okay so there's you've trigger okay so I
think you've triggered the bug we're
we're we're certain certain boxes don't
display if if they're blank rows it's
it's really funky but so I think you're
seeing the boxes I know if you do normal
of that and maybe grid data set of that
yeah it's it's all the number forms
inside of grumpy that's I mean a lot of
things have been lost I mean the like
here why okay that's just because there
are no row nems okay so it randomly it
stripped off row and column names what
we already knew that was going to happen
cuz that was an incomplete feature of
table view yeah okay all right so let's
go back again to what we actually want
here okay what is the functionality
we're really trying to get so one thing
that I consider super useful is being
able to get you know I've got okay let's
look at what the workflow is I've
generated some data I've generated some
data okay let me let me give an example
here right so let's say I do random
integer 10 comma 5 5 okay and now I say
I want to edit that I want to get rid of
the zeros for example or whatever that I
want to do okay and then what I say so
look how do I do that so let's imagine I
do this I say table view over that and I
say great I you just go and edit this
let me go click there and I'm gonna take
that and turn it into minus 1 I'm gonna
click there I'm going to turn into minus
1 and then I'm done and I want you do
slash slash normal after your control
there right then you're in 60 well yeah
I mean I presumably it's useful to me to
have this table view be preserved
presumably I'm not totally certain that
it is useful but but let's let's I mean
because you could equally well if the
thing has all the information then you
could as well say slash our table view
if you want to get another table view
out in other words if the table view is
exact okay here's a question for John
and others ok does table view I mean
dataset clearly okay does table view
contain any additional information over
and above what is present in the in the
array of in the list array
it can contain style information if you
know and potentially let's see what
other sorts of things certainly style
information when there are headings it
will the headings will be options to the
table view okay so in other words there
is tent there are things in table view
that are not so that's an argument for
keeping table view in the output and
having to do an actual operation like
normal to get rid of the table view yeah
which is consistent with what all of our
other controls do right and also if we
if we if we had it automatically remove
itself that means whenever you can write
whenever you program it program
programmatically generated an interface
that involved table view somehow they
can see what you just saw here guys guys
guys listen I am not at all certain that
there's just one function here well let
me say back your earlier idea to have
you know some widget on the table of you
that can you know just paste out his
contents I think that's a pretty
reasonable idea right and similarly I
think if data set had a you know tried
to convert to table view that I I I'm
not sure I'm necessarily sold on that
but it you know but right you know
basically the table view of data set is
I mean cuz I can correct me if I'm wrong
but it's doing some sort of normal and
possibly rearranging of things to try to
make it into into a matrix or or at
least a rate you know that's sort of two
lists of lists and why not just you know
if that if you want to do that sort of
destructive operation then why not just
do table view of normal of data set and
then you know what you've lost well fair
enough but but look look one issue is
the very dramatic graphical difference
between table view and data set here I
mean we've got you know to be clear
we've got three things here right we've
got grid as well
and you know it's kind of weird we're
looking at these three things they look
different I mean it's good that they
look different because they are
different well I mean but of course I
mean grid only looks different because
you've done grid with zero options right
and if you write with enough options you
could make it right now this dataset
work if not by creating you know you
know yeah you know how this dataset
display itself if not by creating grids
and I know maybe it's directly creating
grid boxes rather than grids but okay so
so let's go back a few things by the
call is complaining about this extra box
around data set I don't even know why we
have that anybody know why we have that
because if you have enough I mean look
at one of the bigger data sets right
it's so that you know that the it's to
hold all the extra stuff so you know
it's one thing as opposed to having sort
of disembodied scrollbars
yeah I mean there's an argument that
there should be an appearance option I
don't know why Chris isn't here but but
I originally invited him and he declined
so okay but in a case that's the thing
maybe for Jose that maybe there should
be an appearance option for data set
that can remove that out of frame I
don't know design question but it seems
to me that having an appearance option
which could select between different
themes for that would be a good thing
and and you may remember that you know
we recycled quite a bit on on the extra
frame and we ultimately decided that you
know having it there when it's not
necessary is better than not having it
there when it is necessary and you know
having disemboweled floating yeah you
know pieces of it fair enough but but
why don't we have an appearance option
which control yeah I'm all in favor of
that I'm just saying that this is why
as the default having wasted tweaks that
okay all right
so so let's again go back to what this
is about
okay so a call is pointing out here that
you know a very common thing to want to
do is to say oops there's a mistake in
the data in the data set um the you know
let's um I want to edit that that cell
and they said yeah and you can't you
can't even copy it out
Oh we now have copied to something the
clipboard that I I guess I hadn't
discovered that button yet
let me ask this question is there any
good reason why we don't allow editing
even at the level of a right-click I
mean a level of a right-click we
certainly could could edit I mean it's a
more it's a lot more apparatus to be
able to edit and a lot more issues to be
able to edit directly but at the
right-click level I would have thought
it was possible I really think that
would depend on the type setting and I
think yeah only Chris can really answer
that but also doesn't that get back to
my issue at the beginning of the meeting
I mean right now we're talking about you
know having to do multiple clicks to get
there but even so all we have is the
output right so and do we really want to
and modify the data set in place and not
worry about how many other variables
that's been assigned to you and that
sort of thing
yes it's like everything else that we
could edit an output I mean the the
question of whether there's a copy down
is another question
oh I see so so but but but now I'm
wondering about the utility of editing
at an output I'm loading reflected
anywhere in memory well well then we
could evaluate it again right yeah what
the heck just happened there oh that was
a some in it went from out from output
into an input so no I
I was confused by the stringiness of it
and that was because I had entered that
specifically yeah although it shouldn't
that's it it should not it should have
kept it as a number it's I think it got
confused by the negative sign that's
that's bug all right but but so another
point here is this didn't copy down okay
and I know that was a decision made many
years ago what didn't copy down I'm
sorry okay so if I were to type
something like five six seven okay and
now I start editing this mm-hmm wait am
I totally confused it changed to an
input zone
no it changes toe but the brackets are
updating in real-time or something yeah
there's I don't know why it's grouping
that way that's start typing a new cell
and I bet it loses the outer bracket on
the five six seven I think that's a bug
but uh but women wasn't it the case for
millions of years that there's a cop oh
is this the copy down but it turns in
its yeah that it it's it's so you can
think of it as an alighted copy down
it's just replaced it in place
essentially what what causes pure copy
down there's an option to control it and
it's all right now right but don't I
sometimes get well I mean the behavior
we're seeing right now is good except
for that weird cell grouping thing ya
know it's it's it's kind of an awkward
option naming that I was never happy
with and was not personally responsible
for the original option was cell edit
duplicates and then we have the cell
edit duplicate makes copy because
sometimes you want to duplicate without
making a copy it's a bit of a
head-scratcher but that's what it is and
it's what it's been for a while okay so
what's the difference between those two
between which two options oh sorry so a
dupe
it is whether it does anything at all
and so at a duplicate makes copy is
whether it converts it in place or
whether it makes an actual copy I see
and and and and leaves the original out
untouched yeah okay all right so it's
basically we took a two valued option
and we turned it into a three valued
option by adding a second option allowed
all four values 15 years ago yeah yeah
that really sounds like one option which
should have had like another yes really
should have okay let's come back to this
all right so what we've got here
you know this solution of I want to edit
in a data set I've got a data set but I
want to edit something we want to figure
out what workflow should support that
recognizing that fully editing a data
set is a very complicated matter because
if I get my general data set here and I
drill into you know somewhere deep down
in Himmel amalia which i've never heard
of moon of jupiter um you know and i'm
drilled down here and I decide oh I've
got the radius of that moon wrong um you
know and now I want to edit this right
so that's that's an operation that would
seem to me to be a useful thing with the
turn it into an input cell let me
understand something else
okay very naive question which I should
know the answer to if I take one of
these if I take the data set I take it
and I start putting it in I put in an
input cell oh my gosh that is not good
okay so that's our first bug asaurus yes
we know about that one um Chris has a
fix
okay alright so fine so so then um I'll
though I would point out that any fix
may very well break editing because if
you turn off show string styles that
show string characters yes then you know
the editing behavior because there isn't
any editing the thing is under but but
right but I'm saying that if that that
you know fixing this by turning off show
string characters may make editing
difficult to impossible ok but but so to
me a flow that would be pretty
reasonable is that something and it
might not just be clicking because
clicking okay so clicking on a label
cooking on one of these does nothing
right and it could do something it could
bring up a menu or something like that
right yeah and rather than just getting
you into an inputs mode
you know if the goal is oh I want to
edit some of these it might be nicer to
just go in sort of spreadsheet style I
mean of course remembering that's quotes
spreadsheets so we got two styles of
editing one of these things we've got
the grid style where the thing changes
size as you at it and we've got the kind
of table view spreadsheet style where it
doesn't change size where it keeps the
structure of the whole grid right now so
one thing we might hope for in a data
set is that you click and it lets you
add it now in a perfect world maybe it
would let you edit directly maybe not
even obvious that's the best the best
idea but to at least give you a menu
that would allow you to edit does seem
like a nice thing and then the question
is what would that mean so assume the
thing has been copied down to an input
so that it is an input you know so it's
an input right because because we can
see that you can put a data set as a
piece of input there's nothing wrong
with doing that and it will then be
adjusted properly right yep as long as
it's not too big right that's subject to
dollar in notebook inline storage limit
just like summary boxes are okay because
for example file backed data sets
couldn't
let's think about that comment um
did Chris just join yes we've been
asking a lot of things to do with data
set um ah we've been talking about an
appearance option so that we can get rid
of the outer frame I think that's fairly
straightforward but maybe that's already
in there and the dot on the docket is it
know should be okay then the the main
thing we've been talking about is the
relationship between data set table view
and some other things I'm not sure why
you thought you shouldn't be in this
meeting maybe there's something I don't
know
well the agenda items that I saw were
were not my things okay well so so I
take care of data set things that
involve the front end things that
involve just the kernel Hosea's okay
fine so so so one of the issues is um
you know people want to have some
workflow for editing in a data set right
and the question is how do we achieve
that
well what you suggested in the past was
that you click on something you can't
get like a pop up editing thing to edit
that cell well I just suggested the same
thing again um I wonder if we if well I
mean maybe this is a minor
implementation difference but I wonder
if what you get is like an attached cell
right that's a or box that right so it's
off to the side or something that oh I
think that was the idea okay but so the
question that we're now as banal before
us is we've got three constructs grid
data set table view okay hm and they all
deal with tabular data right and I think
there's the there's the question and
they all have you know grid is very much
an output story as a low level output
story and arguably we shouldn't be kind
of promoting it as a
common thing I mean it should be a
promoted only maybe as an output story
I mean grid you mean grid I was well yes
and that is exactly how it is promoted
well except that I for example quite
often use it to enter data now maybe in
today's world I should be using table
view but if I'm going to use table view
here's the very very typical workflow
okay
I have a machine generated thing that I
got from who knows where and I want to
edit it that is that is the workflow
that I'm trying to follow so any weird
nonsense with dynamics and this that and
the other totally irrelevant not what I
want
mmm what I want is I've got this blob of
data I mean like like for instance I've
got um you know I've got something I
don't know what I must have had this
even the last few days you know I've got
a thing I had recently oh who knows you
know I've got a table of mappings
between references to this and that and
I want to conveniently edit them I mean
form notebooks will provide yet another
way to do these things but by using
different cells for different data
elements but in this case we're using
different rows of a tabular structure
right and this so you know that's my
workflow is I've got something it's I've
got an existing piece of data it's from
a file for example I want to update
what's in that file I want to bring it
into something that I can conveniently
and tabular ly edit and I want to send
it back out again that's what I want to
do I don't want any nonsense with
controls anything like that that's
that's the story so what's the best way
to do that I mean right now I often use
grid to do things like that but I think
table View is a better solution isn't it
or something like table view something
you uses the code base of table view
I mean if table view is being taken for
some kind of weird control thing okay so
that's that's a workflow do we agree
that that's a workflow that is important
sure
okay John do you understand in it I do
you understand and agree that that's an
important workflow this is so let me
make sure I didn't miss anything so
basically you have some generated data
you want to inspect it fix any things
then assign it to something and continue
with your machine processing it doesn't
necessarily have to be assigned to
anything I mean it's just I just want to
I want to have that data and continue
doing something I might want to write it
out to a file I might want to do all
kinds of things to it okay yeah that
that's a very common workflow the
problem I always have with that kind of
thing is what do you get when you edit
do you get a string do you get a number
do you get something else how do you
determine what what you get well and I
don't think that's quite right yet in
table fields okay I mean I don't think
it's quite right but we're guessing that
that's a separate issue to be solved
right and and it could very well be that
we should be doing something which is
some kind of auto detect and table view
where if we've got a big table where
everything seems to be a number that
mostly a number is what you're gonna get
am I making sense John with inserts
matrix menu could have insert something
to specify the properties nobody ever
uses that penny I think that menu is
gonna go the way of the and by nobody
you mean you don't that will be a
correct translation I mean I have used
it but it's um I mean I'll be honest I
don't use it very often but I've
certainly answered questions about it
yeah and I have used it I'm not sure
it's the best way to get what you want
there I mean what you're getting there
see see look look I I think we're
getting confused by talking about table
viewers of control I think we have
something with the same functionality
that isn't a control because one of the
things that will be very useful is just
make me a table that is
well actually I don't know that by
default shows some number of rows and
columns make me a table view or a table
view like thing that shows a set number
of rows and columns that is expandable
am i making sense John you understand
what I'm saying
and interpreted as a list of lists
ultimately yes when it's well whether it
is whether that happens on chef dente'
or whether that's something that I get
from normal I'm not sure so and you know
this is of course because of the order
in which things were developed but in
part but but grid box is you know it's
not a control but it is like that it is
interpreted as a list of lists well yeah
right and well I'm saying that there's a
lot of features in tableview right which
are desirable grid box and grid was not
really intended as a major editing you
know data cleaning environment yeah and
you know and we've we've played with the
idea of having you know controls that
are a part of you know kind of you know
more literate sort of programming or
something the it's it's always bothered
me that to do that you either have to
you know explicitly wrap setting around
it so you just make the code more
verbose or you have to have some kind of
you know weird typeset thing which I
mean if you know what you're doing you
can create just fine but you know that
like a slider that is that evaluates as
a number not as a slider of a number
yeah I know I know I know
I mean well that that is the defer
mechanism that is it - for what what is
the mechanism dynamic setting okay
right so dynamic setting so if I say
something like F of I mean but then I
have to I have to do F of dynamic
setting slider and then I have to go
command enter that and now I get my
slider and now it's yes yes I mean
that's beautiful functionality crummy
way to get it right and and I'm bringing
this up because I think when you're
talking about this in the context of
table view I think there are a number I
think this is more
Rolle issue right I mean I this is very
that we might like to crack in other
places right I mean colors it's also
very useful to be able to yes absolutely
well so really what this is about
you know if you want a slider and you're
going to get it by typing the only way
you can have it turn into a visible
slider is why by evaluate in place I
think I mean the only other possibility
would be which is something we could do
is have a palette that basically puts a
slider in there not a completely crazy
thing to do I mean I don't yeah but I
don't know how much people would use it
but it's it's it's certainly one way
that this could be done yes
I mean it's similarly for colors and
things like that but it's something I
had not thought up before but it would
be a somewhat reasonable thing to do I
mean you know to have a slider that's
been optimized for basically you know
okay so let me be even more extreme
maybe we should have an escape SL escape
that just puts a slider in somewhere
puts a dynamic setting slider in maybe
maybe now the issue with a dynamic
setting slider is that right I mean I
will point out that the one big issue
with that is that you could only ever
have sliders from 0 to 1 with an escape
sequence i I know but there might be
some way to fix that or it might be that
that's actually you know already very
very useful
um I think checkboxes for boolean x'
would be even more useful a dynamic
setting checkbox okay so you're
suggesting an escape code and a palette
basically that just enters those things
no you were suggesting that I'm saying
it makes sense for checkboxes in my
opinion well you're right I agree with
you completely um but but I mean let's
just understand that the semantics of
what would happen there so there's a
checkbox there and as soon as you
evaluate that is equivalent to true for
example a
evaluation so you only see it in your
input code right in your typeset input
code yes in a front-end and in in a non
front-end you would see dynamic setting
of checkbox open close and that's okay
we'll just evaluate to whatever it
evaluates to and it's a bit ugly but
it's not harmful
yeah this is an interesting car okay
this is a great thing this we've had a
good idea so at least for today we can
put one pin in the good idea category
this would be this is a good thing we
should have both appellate version under
an escape code version if somebody can
make up a list of things that we maybe
Lou could make up a list of things for
which we should do this if is there an
obvious reason why you know actually the
one way to do this would be also as
something that comes from our completion
and there you can you know you can have
a very good idea oh this thing takes a
color so we'll just throw a color widget
in the possible completion excellent
good idea excellent idea
all right and if it takes a range of
numbers then we might know because we
know what function were completed in do
that this is a range from zero to one or
from you know negative one to one or
whatever right but so I mean what this
then allows is with an option which can
be true or false we could allow that as
one of the option value settings a
checkbox that will be really cool really
cool great idea um I mean my question is
in the escape code stuff is it totally
obvious that we can't have parametrized
escape codes that you can't say escape
sl1 comma seven I mean yes we certainly
could implement such a thing I'm not
sure that we should but we could what
I'm not sure that we should I simply
mean I'm not sure that anyone would
really actually use it is what I mean no
I agree with you I mean I agree the only
thing I can imagine is that something
like sl5 a slider from one to five might
be quite useful well I could tell you
that Emacs users would would use it
except they'd expected in the order
escape number and then the control
well okay so Lu can you try and make up
a list of things like this that we could
have it look something like SL n not the
special linear group I understand okay
all right so let's come back to our
question here of of so somebody was
complaining about the thing that it's
just freaking weird why does this look
so different from these other other
things is a different font size or what
is it that makes this look so different
is this for some reason a larger font
size nu and I think it's data set that
has two special fonts actually I mean if
you I mean I don't know if that's a list
of lists or a list or a data set
containing associations but you could
try grid of normal of the data set okay
I mean I mean maybe it should be a
smaller font there maybe instead of
using exactly the output font maybe we
should take it down up pointers you know
it just looks very clunky but I mean
okay the should say it's also the case
that you know most spreadsheets don't
use monospace fonts we are using a
monospace font here why well I mean
because that is our normal thing I mean
maybe it doesn't make you know IIIi
think I think it's something that merits
the the merits discussion you know it's
not clear to me that one is you know
which one is definitely superior
which is what you got Bret so isn't it
common in spreadsheets that the display
depends you know sort of on what the
type is yeah so like left to right the
Montes typically uniform unless you've
actually you know styled it right oh
you're saying whether it goes to the
left or the right of the cell well so
there's
I mean yeah there's all kinds of things
that you can configure in terms of you
know styling background alignment so on
well one of the things is you know
oftentimes fields will have a datatype
and so like you know it might be a
currency or a date or something like
that and some of those types bring along
some style information with them so the
typically alignments okay but okay by
the way what my idea is that you know we
could use a different font for common
types numbers string whatever but
experts are mano spaced yeah that's it's
possible yes I mean I think it wouldn't
be bad to distinguish those things in
some hint type way you know Carla's
commenting on the live stream that he
thinks dataset looks really nice since
one of the big reasons he uses it in
notebooks and I agree you know I agree
with that I think it looks nice and I
agree that it is that is a big attractor
for people including myself to use it
and right now tableview looks extremely
konkey um although tableview i view as
being much more of a you know it's once
you once you take the cover off you're
seeing all the electronics inside so to
speak it's the thing that you I don't
think it's the thing that you mostly
would have as a piece of output display
do people agree with that claim exactly
and and that sort of part of why I was
thinking you know mixing table view and
data set maybe maybe what we really need
is like a I know data set table or
something that they write because you
also loot right when you do this you
lose the information of was this an
association or was this a list of lists
etc it's it's it's a pretty Lawson to
just sort of auto magically happen I
know I agree but I mean this is just
like if you go into a grid you lose you
know grid can't preserve associations
well it does but it also doesn't it
doesn't corrupt them
just leaves them there it's my point
what with the corruption coming in well
if you actively doing normal on the data
set if you go to the example I showed
you of already got it I already got it I
mean the basic point is that table view
of data set is a hacky destructive
operation at the present time and right
or particularly objecting to the fact
that is hacky you're dimension of
happiness is it doesn't behave like a
control because it's doing evaluation
another function of happiness is it's
blowing you know it's kind of drilling
into the data set and sucking out random
pieces of it and not preserving other
parts right okay so what there are two
levels of happiness and we have
certainly talked about is supporting
associations but the just we haven't
there probably some design questions
that raises that we haven't broached yet
all right it's never going to support
the hierarchical stuff that data set
supports it is not in its nature I mean
if we act that is absolutely correct yes
that's right that means so the basic
point is okay let me try it a different
way table view perhaps incorrectly named
is the is taking a two-dimensional view
of a thing which could be a slice of a
data set and allowing you to edit it so
it's taking a two-dimensional projection
of something and allowing editing so for
example for data set I claim what it
should do is that the cells of the table
view I mean it it is not a very nice
thing if you have a deep data set that
is much more than you know than
two-dimensional then what should happen
is in table view it should just have
those sub datasets he's sitting there
inside the cells of the table view
perhaps not very useful but at least
consistent and if you want to edit it so
in other words what you're always doing
is you're taking a two-dimensional slice
through the data set that is that might
be an eighth dimensional object you're
taking a two-dimensional slice somewhere
in the data set you are projecting that
on to this sort of table view editing
plane where you can then edit and then
we need to have a good mechanism for you
inserting that edited thing back into
the data set but my claim is that you're
always wanting to edit on this sort of
two-dimensional plane and if there is
greater depth and some of the elements
in that two-dimensional plane we need
another mechanism for you to deal with
those and it's not just splatter them
out into the into the table view does
that make sense I got a little lost and
okay so I'm gonna try it again because I
really think this is right okay okay
what is table view table view is an
editor of two-dimensional projections of
data okay do we agree yep sure okay okay
data set is an arbitrary dimensional
hierarchical representation of data
right yep okay imagine that we have
taken you know this thing here where it
Jupiter moons and we've gone down to
Phoebe okay that thing there is a nice
two dimensional object yet that could
perfectly well be edited by by by table
view if we allowed it to be sucked out
put in table view push back in again
right but let me go back out to Jupiter
okay this is no longer such a nice clean
two-dimensional thing because that moons
thing is a deeper piece of data right so
my claim is if you were to take it at
this level and say let me edit it in
data in in table view this moons thing
would just be a lump of deeper data that
would not be read it'll readily editable
other than maybe
Elita door something right although
these things here because they are at
that level are perfectly well editable
and so in other words what I'm claiming
is that what we should be doing the way
we should be thinking about it is that
table view is something that takes
two-dimensional slices of data sets and
provides an editing view of those
two-dimensional slices with a mechanism
for stuffing it back into the day set I
don't understand that mechanism yet well
then that's my big question because
we've already shown that stuffing back
into data set is is not a thing that
seems to be well supported right I
understand because because we didn't
really have a thing that was a very
interesting restoring I mean so data set
one form of Reece nothing is um to to
have them to use it as an l-value
that's one way of restoring I'm not sure
that's the best way to read stuff things
and so I you know I basically agree with
what you said up until the very end
where you said date of view table view
is a thing that eats data sets because I
think tables view or something that I'm
not saying that I'm saying it eats
two-dimensional projections yes and and
that's what I disagree with I think that
is a different function I think team
could be a different function I'm saying
a function with a bunch of the
functionality of table view I've said
from the beginning of this meeting it's
not obvious to me that there's one
function here right because I think of
table right so table view table you know
there's table view which is right it
takes you know right to do lists of
lists let's just say it simply it takes
lists of lists and gives you a
spreadsheet like interface to editing
those lists of lists and apparently
doing it badly at the moment or at least
ugly you know so I agree that there is a
place for a function which takes a data
set but then also some specification of
a two-dimensional
through it and gives you a nice editable
thingamabob whatever that thing about is
right and so my right so but those extra
options don't make anything sense for
anything other than sort of a data set
which is why I'm feeling this other
evaluation behavior is a mistake maybe
we need to wait until we have the second
function well III don't I'm not
necessarily supporting the auto
evaluation behavior which I understand
is the beginning of this meeting I'm
saying that what look what we're doing
here is we're compromising we've got a
design for table view we're trying to
make sure you know it really is a it
really is a control we're trying to give
it a few other pieces of functionality
because we know these other pieces of
functionality are really valuable but
we're trying to keep it as a control as
well this is not going to work mm-hmm
we're gonna end up with two functions
here yep and and you know one thing that
is front and center of control and you
know walks and talks like that and
something that is not a control but
probably is implemented using the table
view control as a very trivial wrapper
on top of that control that's an
expectation yeah and I'm not bothered by
that sort of construction at all there
are plenty of precedents for it there's
a technical issue here so a data set has
a type and the contents of the data set
have to match the type otherwise you've
got to recompute the data set from
scratch and figure out what its new type
is which may cause the dataset to
completely reconfigure so if you don't
want it to reconfigure itself the table
view has to restrict the kinds of things
you can put in a in a slot to a
particular type okay you can do to a
limited extent rate the grant to maybe
this does not have that right the point
is that there's a type calculus for data
sets sadly not quite the same as the
type calculus for the compiler but
similar um and the issue is to use that
as a as something which is a
constraining you know a type
constraining
thing four foot four table view but
let's talk about what the correct flow
is if the goal is just to have table
view Prime the thing that is I was
calling thing me Bob um table view prime
which is the you know which is the I
don't know what we call it I mean let's
say let's call it some table editor or
something it's a terrible name not not
there but okay well you could call it
tabular slice no because we really want
to get across the idea that's editable I
see
I mean it's some table editor let's
let's just say table editor for now sure
okay
so then I mean okay so so a naive way to
do this would be to simply say oh god
that score is so weird um okay so we
would say table editor okay so you type
in table editor and you would give it
something like table editor of six seven
and that would give you a table view of
a certain size it would be my vision of
it and then table editor would and by
the way it from a data set you will be
able to call up a table editor through a
menu basically from the data set that is
you've drilled into the data set and you
then and it says okay you are at a slice
level wherever I had that of my boy
that's so weird
um wherever I had that up here right
you're at a slice where it is meaningful
to do at it took to invoke the table
editor okay so let's imagine we're at
this slice you know one of these at this
slice here it could be meaningful at all
slices but but maybe it invokes the
table editor only on the parts that can
be meaningfully be table edited um the
okay it invokes the table editor here
what would that look like to invoke the
table editor because because the whole
point is you've got a trailing data set
in other words you only want to invoke
the table editor on that slice you've
still got the rest of the data set
hanging out there waiting in the wings
for when that slices has been finished
being edited because then that slice
wants to get reinserted into the whole
data set so that's a different thing
that we've had before it's more like an
image editor or something where you edit
a few pixels and the way we've tend to
do that like for image editing is with
an attached cell yeah yeah and I mean we
can certainly do a table view as well so
the thing I don't like about this I mean
by the way some comments on the live
stream have said that that being able to
store a symbolic representation of what
you edited would be highly useful I
don't know whether we have that I mean I
don't know whether we you know in a
sense our editor in all these years
right and this is something maybe we
will be changing in the future but in
all these years just the editing
operations on a notebook do not
represent a symbolic stream we don't
represent that symbolically I mean when
we do if you wanted to play back a bunch
of edits I don't think maybe you do have
a symbolic representation it's part of
the the undo mechanism John the sorry I
hadn't really been thinking about it
that way but yes in principle that's
that's possible right I mean right you
can store in principle play back the the
edit you know play back the state of the
boxes if you had them recorded somehow
I'm know but I'm talking about the
operations like I typed an X yeah you
know at this position I moved my mouse
to that position I moved the cursor etc
etc I mean it's the kind of thing that
web execute does for a browser it's not
beautiful either how it does it you know
in browser control it's not beautiful
it's it's one of these
you know Dom poking exercises right I
mean so one of the things Jason Harris
loves to do is to write create a dynamic
of the Box expression of a cell and then
when you type into that cell you see the
snapshots of the Box expression which in
some level is a representation of all of
your keystrokes in that box but it's not
a very useful one um there's a question
from Brian on live streaming good points
which is he's asking about undo in table
editing so is there doing table editing
the right now but yes yes it would
certainly support if it I mean if it
doesn't now it's just a limitation of
where we're at the developments it
definitely should support multiple do
okay okay and and there's no fundamental
reason you know that you know in this
context it would work a lot like input
field yeah um so Carla's saying dynamic
of data set flows nicely it's clear
you're editing your data set yes the
problem is that we don't have a
mechanism for editing the whole data set
and I don't even understand how I don't
think dynamic of data set is quite right
because you'd be saying dynamic X equals
data sets dynamic of AX dynamic data set
by itself doesn't quite work unless it's
inside of a inside of a control you know
we just been a different thing yeah and
then data set of dynamic doesn't quite
work because you you know data set isn't
the control it's a proper wrapper that
should it must I want to come back again
here to this you know what is the
workflow we would like for you know okay
so I've got to this state I have an
attached cell the attached cell can
bring up a table editor yeah okay that's
one possibility
another possibility is I would like okay
but let me just try to understand if I'm
doing this on to be able to take the
slice of the data set okay edit it then
reinsert the result so I guess the
operation that is missing is to be here
and to have an attached cell that just
says take this thing that I'm about to
paste in and make that be this part of
the data set so I'm saying so in other
words you're doing well okay okay so you
may think that I'm asking too you know
diving too deep into something technical
but it seems foundational to me so where
when you're doing all this where does
the data set live where does the actual
data live does it live in the front end
or does it live in the kernel yeah well
I think what lives in the front end is
the table editor slice I think so as you
probably know you know unless it's a
trivial data set the you know all the
data for the data set don't live in the
front end no I understand I understand
it so I'm saying that only the table
editor slice lives in the front end when
you say do a table at it then that goes
to the front end and then the front end
is holding that data for editing then
what I'm saying is the stuff back
operation I'll take that thing that I've
just edited the slice I've just edited
and reinsert that slice back into the
right right so where does that happen
does that happen like immediately when
you complete the edit or is it like
sitting there as a payload to be
overlaid as part of a shift enter
operation I think it's I think it's a
payload I don't think it's a I think you
should be able to separately do whatever
monkeying around you want to do with the
table editor and then say given this
data set look I mean it may just be that
there's an operation that we want to
have just a function that just says take
this state of the data set I mean
something which you could do independent
of having got the GUI
set take this thing Jupiter moons
Himalaya okay and just say you know it's
it's basically an l-value type operation
it says take this slice of the data set
and change it I mean it's it's a it's a
replaced part on the data set and it
could actually be replaced part
attention i was objecting vociferously
while muted and and so maybe it's clear
to you but it is not at all clear to me
what is this lel value you you speak of
right so i don't know i think it's a
non-starter i don't think it good
I think the L value is not the
interesting case I think the interesting
case is replaced part
okay so right I'm claiming is that the
right thing is is more or less replaced
part data set you know in this case it
would be Jupiter right and this is a
payload so until you I mean we could
write so we could conceivably have a
button which is you know do this in
place in the output cell but more
probably this would be a payload that
when you shift enter the edited one yeah
what's in place is editing the payload
but you don't get the effect of the
payload until a shift enter happens
right I was I was confused
look what I'm suggesting is that what
happens is you can peel this off okay
there would be a single in place GUI way
of doing this okay which I consider is
is the small case of this because you're
not gonna want to do a 10,000 you know
thing sort of multi-day editing effort
is an in place you know weird attached
cell thing that's for the quick edit you
know I've noticed one mistake I'm gonna
fix it okay
for the other case what you do is you
peel this off you peel off that slice
you go you edit that slice using table
editor and then you say given that this
data set was called des let's say you
simply do a replace part and the return
thing is a new data set which has that
part replaced as is appropriate yeah
it's kind of like and gets peak it's
like you're creating a series of patches
to be applied yes which are applied with
replaced part right that's using to me
why wouldn't you just I mean the way I
imagine where work is you click a button
it brings up the table you editor you
added it you just miss it and when you
dismiss it those things get merged back
into Chris that's absolutely fine I'm
saying that I want a language level
version of how you do that that will
work even if you're doing it in multiple
stages all right even if you have the
table view disembodied out of the table
editor outside and yeah I'm gonna have
to go in a second because I think at
least I'm supposed to be doing a Q&A
about science and technology for kids
this is part of my support the okay even
if I may just very quick question before
you run away so when you write that
table editor of xxx that's really the
return value of that table and that's
what I mean yes that's what I mean
whether you put the table editor in
there you know I don't really mean that
I mean return value yes that's what I
meant and I mean I think look I think
this is a somewhat that this is a
reasonable way to do this and then table
editor becomes it is what it is you know
that's what it is table editor and what
you give so I might be wrong this is
wrong what I said there is wrong well it
would the correct thing when I give
table editor is you know it's table
editor or might even be table edit might
be table edit of initial state right and
that then gives me an editable table
yeah I think this is wrong and then this
and if I wanted to I could say table
edit of and then some options that would
say the size I know what they would be
I'm I Tunes item what is the right thing
max items I don't know what the right
right term is
um something like this whereas the more
generic case will be just table at it of
a other thing I need to go because I'm
supposed to be doing something
completely different than I need
something to eat before I do that um and
uh okay that this was actually very
fruitful I think a bunch of good ideas
sorry Danny and raava and Constantine I
hope you were able to be productive and
in the background okay for another time
okay there's more to discuss here but
but um this was great
thanks guys see you later